[musique]
Alain Dono, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Reux. Petit problème technique mais on
recommence. On vous reçoit pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview.
On est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Euh je suis directeur de
programme au Collège international de
philosophie, auteur d'essais sur euh
notamment des euh le rôle des
multinationales, le pouvoir des
multinationales en prenant pour exemple
des euh
entités dans le domaine minier et
pétrolier. Je me suis intéressé aux
paradis fiscaux, aux législations de
complaisance sous un angle conceptuel et
j'ai aussi euh cherché à euh décortiquer
euh des euh notions idéologiques comme
celle de gouvernance.
J'ai regardé votre interview dans le
média
avec Odonelin et vous la vous la
terminer en abordant la relation de
cause à effet entre consommation
énergétique et capitalisme.
Est-ce que vous pouvez développer un peu
plus euh
bah pas très souvent dans le monde
militant euh et au-delà chez les
citoyennes et citoyens qui sont inquiets
par
euh euh
l'emprise qu'on les grandes banques et
les multinationales dans le domaine de
l'industrie
sur le cours historique des choses. On a
l'impression qu'il nous revient à nous,
pauvres gens de renverser ce système en
ayant en tête une représentation de la
de la résistance politique et de
l'engagement politique
de l'ordre de ce qui s'est passé en
octobre 17 à savoir qu'il nous
reviendrait de renverser
une oligarchie qui détient tellement de
pouvoir qui a Ça portait tellement de
leviers en ce qui concerne la sécurité,
les médias, la pharmaceutique,
l'agroalimentaire, l'énergie, le
transport, sans parler de de l'influence
directe qu'on s pouvoir priver sur les
appareils politiques, sur les partis
politiques de gouvernement. Et on se dit
mais dient entre par où commencer ? Bon
euh je pense que
c'est une erreur de prendre sur nous en
fait c cet objectif qui serait de nous
nous petites organisations, nous
hackers, nous
intellectuels, nous
de de de renverser ce système dans la
mesure où il est cancérigène, dans la
mesure où
il est il n'est pas viable. Le problème
souvent, c'est que les marxistes ont
tellement euh se sont tellement trompés
souvent depuis 150 ans en prédisant la
fin du capitalisme qu'on a fini par
penser que le capitalisme ne finirait
jamais. On ne fini par le voir comme
étant euh comme étant si fort, comme
ayant une capacité d'adaptation si
grande au aux circonstances que rien ne
pourrait en venir à bout.
Ce n'est pas tant par la lutte des
classes, mais par la crise écosystémique
euh qui vient euh que ce système-là
euh en viendra d'une manière très
visible et manifeste à battre de l'aile
et à montrer ses dysfonctionnements, sa
faiblesse,
son le caractère irresponsable de
l'idéologie
sur laquelle il repose, notamment ce qui
regarde la question énergétique et
minière,
c'est le premier élément, j'ai
l'impression en plus des des des
secousses écosystémiques qui produisent
des ouragans plus qu'avant, le
réchauffement climatique,
la montée du cru des eaux, la l'érosion
des sols, l'avancée des déserts et quoi
encore comme secours et conséquences
graves. Vous savez qu'en Allemagne en
quelques décennies 75 % des insectes ont
disparu qu' a une 30 en Amérique du Nord
30 % des abeilles ont disparu. En France
30 % des oiseaux de champ ont disparu.
On perd sur la planète à chaque année
l'équivalent de la Belgique en forêt et
le rester le reste. Donc en plus de ces
ces ces ces ces ces conséquences graves,
ce régime là ne peut pas tenir ses
promesses parce qu'il est si gourmand en
l'énergie qu'il en est aujourd'hui.
C'est symptomatique. Faut faut se faut
faut procéder par
autocensure pour ne pas le voir. Ce ce
ce système là en est à chercher du
pétrole dans de la boue, hein, ce qu'on
appelle les sables bitubineux dans
l'Ouest canadien par exemple ou encore à
3000 m sous les eaux dans des conditions
tout à fait hasardeuses au large de
l'Angola ou ailleurs. c'est-à-dire des
puits qui n'intéressaient personne il y
a 30 ou 40 ans parce qu'on a tellement
poussé les frontières de l'extractivisme
qu'on en est désespérément pour
maintenir le le volume d'activité de ce
ce régime là à chercher des richesses
énergétiques dans des conditions
presque désespérées. Vous savez qu'en
Alberta par exemple dans certains
contextes, il faut brûler trois baris de
pétrole pour en extérieur 5. C'est
abérin. Et ensuite,
on a en ce qui concerne le gaz
des méthodes là tout à fait
problématique en ce qui concerne les
nappes fréatiques,
l'hydrofracturation
pour effectivement obtenir dans le chel
c'estàd en gros dans des cailloux là des
des extraits des des des parts de de de
gaz quoi qui qui sont qui sont là aussi
une faç façon de repousser les les
frontières de l'extractivisme quand il
s'agit pas sinon de
Philippe Bwix en a parlé éloquemment
dans auprès de vous de de de chercher à
développer des des des formes de
transition qui sont tellement gourmands
dans richesse minière qu'elles n'ont pas
d'avenir là non plus. Donc ce système
qui consiste à à
militer par la croissance la croissance
du capital du capital de ceux qui en ont
en faisant des promesses
à au parti prenant d'une société de
consommation qui eux auraient toujours à
disposition l'abondance, l'abondance
pour le tourisme, l'abondance pour la
consommation dans le domaine
alimentaire, l'abondance dans le domaine
électronique. Ce système là ne tiendra
pas ses promesses et il arrivera un
moment où il y aura des pannes
d'électricité ici comme il y en a déjà
dans même pays d'Afrique sur une base
régulière. Il y aura des moments où
pendant quelques heures, quelques jours,
il y aura pénurie dans les supermarchés
comme c'était le cas à Moscou euh à la
fin du régime soviétique. Il y aura des
moments où les signes pénurie d'essence
dans les stations service par exemple,
il y aura des signes suffisamment grands
pour qu'on comprenne que ce régime là ne
tient pas ses promesses et cela sera
l'indice de problèmes beaucoup plus
profonds qui amènera qui amèneront les
gens à douter et à douter au point où le
système vacillera. Vous savez, Rosa
Luxembourg explique en quoi quelles sont
les conditions de possibilité de la
révolution. C'est d'une part lorsque je
dirais pas une majorité mais une
minorité intense, une minorité qui a
valeur de peuple, doute hein du la
teneur idéologique des discours
hégémoniques. Doute de ce que nous dit
BFM TV à flutendu à longueur de journée.
Doute de ce que nous raconte Jean-Michel
Apati à longueur de journée. Doute de ce
que nous racontera François l'anglais à
longueur de journée. finit par trouver
risible ces assertions. De la même
manière qu'en Union soviétique dans les
années 80, on jugeait risible les
ministres qui venaient nous dire que le
lendemain, il y aurait approvisionnement
dans les dans les boutiques du régime.
Et cette crise de confiance qui sera
majeure, qui sera de moins en moins
marginale et qui va gagner en importance
pourra donner lieu à une transformation
radicale si tentez qu'il y a par
ailleurs des perspectives
enjouées, désirables, stimulantes,
convaincantes, c'est dire des modèles
qu'on commence à développer ça et là
Marie Monique Robin montre dans son film
Qu'est-ce qu'on attend ? une communauté
alacienne qui a pris sur elle de
développer un mode de vie qui est le
sien
sur la base de la souveraineté
intellectuelle, souveraineté
énergétique, souveraineté alimentaire,
vous avez l'azade, vous avez des des des
cas qui sont des projets pilotes, des
expériences mené à taton qui semblent
aujourd'hui tout à fait dérisoire et qui
sont en même temps les modèles de
demain.
La fonction exponentielle, ça vous parle
euh comme ça ? Oui,
une courbe de gosse.
Oui,
on a une consommation exponentielle
d'énergie. On a une consommation, une
production de monétaire exponentiel.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans vos
modélisations quand la courbe fait un
plateau ou s'inverse ?
On sait pas tout à fait les les les
références par lesquelles je passe pour
penser la situation, mais elle entre en
corrélation avec ce que je mets en
perspective. ce qui ce qui ce qui
m'intéresse par rapport à à tous ces
phénomènes liés à la limite, aux
contraintes, aux principes de réalité,
ce que des enfants comprennent, ce qu'on
apprend aux enfants, hein. Euh
c'est cette
posture ou imposture qui consiste pour
les pouvoirs d'abord à se jeter à corps
perdu dans des perspectives qui sont
pour le coup irresponsables, délétaires
et voir destructrices et catastrophiques
à terme, mais continuellement emballé en
ce ces prises de position là de discours
linifiant. En par exemple, il est clair
pour une société pétrolière aujourd'hui
qu'on arrive à un point où extraire du
pétrole va devenir extrêmement onéreux.
Bon, difficile sur un plan technique.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On se dit
on on diversifie
he les les réserves, les types d'énergie
qui sont les siennes. C'est le cas de
total exemplairement. Donc on va
développer la filière du gaz du gaz de
Shell et on va présenter
euh je vais y revenir comme on va
présenter mais on on est
et ensuite on va développer ce qu'il en
est de l'électricité à partir du gaz et
il y aura ensuite toute la filière
éolienne qui sera en cause.
Ensuite, les agrocarburants, le solaire
pour devenir une énergéticienne
parce que il y a le problème pétrolier à
la base, c'est dire le problème de
l'approvisionnement donc qui se pose
désormais à terme. Mais dans un deuxième
temps, on se dit bon, il faut bien
emballer tout ça pour le bon peuple.
Alors, on confie à une équipe de
marketing euh l'élaboration d'un
discours et le discours sera le suivant.
Euh nous excusons nous responsables de
l'industrie pétrolière nous mais coule
pas nous plaidons coupable en ce qui
concerne le réchauffement climatique. Il
est vra nous avons pris conscience du
fait que l'exploitation pétrolière et
toute chose est extrêmement
dommageable pour le climat. Et donc on
va élire la question du climat comme la
cause de prédilection hein euh des
enjeux enfin la question écologique
comme si l'écologie et le climat
devenait synonyme et comme si l'écologie
se réduisait au climat. Et on va même
militer pour une taxe carbone en disant
heureusement il y a le gaz, heureusement
il y a le solaire. Heureusement, il y a
l'électricité à partir du gaz et on pas
on fera passer ces modes
d'exploitation-là comme étant vert,
comme étant euh
solution.
Ouais. de l'ordre de la solution. Et on
dira même euh euh
nous sommes le problème mais nous sommes
aussi la solution. Imaginez des
représentants du crime organisé nous
disant "Nous sommes le problème mais
nous sommes aussi la solution."
Euh
c'est que c'est une phrase qui qui est
arrogante.
Ça s'est déjà vu. Non,
ça s'est déjà vu en effet en Italie.
Ouais, en effet dans
et aux États-Unis avec Kennedy.
En effet, mais donc on a là des gens qui
nous montrent quoi ? D'une part qu'ils
ont
un parti prix, des objectifs, ils ont
investi énormément dans le pétrole. Il
faut vendre ce pétrole, l'écouler pour
le pour qu'il soit brûlé de façon à
rentabiliser des investissements. on ira
au bout de ces processus là et tandis
qu'on continue
de développer
des infrastructures pétrochimiques
tandis qu'on continue d'exploiter en eau
profonde tandis qu'on continue
d'exploiter le les sables bitumineux on
lance d'autres chantiers qui sont et
pour le climat et pour d'autres enjeux
écosystémiques comme les nappes
fréatiques euh préjudiciables comme le
gaz euh le le le gaz par rapport à
l'émission de méthane est vraiment
une filière inquiétante et des des des
formes de de développement qui sont
qui sont là aussi problématiques quant à
l'enjeu minier dont on a déjà parlé.
Est-ce que vous pensez que la population
a les capacités encore de d'appréhender
cette réalité ? Est-ce que la la
population mondiale occidentale
n'est pas trop dans le déni ou dans la
dépendance pour pouvoir avoir
suffisamment de recul et demander un
changement de cap ?
Il y aurait tellement de choses à dire.
Euh il commence, on peut commencer en
disant que le
le dans le cours quotidien des choses,
un sujet
a tendance à souhaiter que les
idéologues disent vrai. Ce serait donc
plus simple si ce qu'on nous raconte
était vrai, qu'en recyclant des
bouteilles de plastique, ça suffit. euh
qu'en achetant des produits qui ont un
petit logo souriant avec euh une fleur
ou je ne sais trop quoi, un soleil qui
nous dit que tout est conforme à des
standards euh écologistes, euh c'est
suffisant. C'est vrai que que Nicolas
Hul est une caution écologique dans un
gouvernement d'extrême centre que bon
tout ça est c'est c'est il y a quandême
une il y a une un désir profond he
que ce que Pierre Lean appelle l'amour
du senseur quoi. Il y a il y a un désir
de croire la censure la la propagande
quoi. Étant donné que ce qu'elle offre
comme perspective est rassurant.
Il est plus facile de de de suivre pour
l'esprit he pour suivre ces discours là
que des discours de Cassandre. Mais
c'est pas tellement ça qui m'inquiète
parce que il y a cette cette évolution
dans la perspective de ce que décrivait
déjà Rosa Luxembourg qui peut nous
donner à penser qu'une évolution
s'observe en en ce qui a trait à des
prises de conscience. Ce qui m'inquiète
davantage aujourd'hui, ce sont toutes
les méthodes qui sont mises en avant.
autant dans le management que dans le
marketing que dans l'industrie
médiatique pour euh
prise de
pulvériser les sujets. C'est-à-dire
qu'on a beaucoup parlé à gauche la
division du travail. Ce qui m'inquiète
moi pour ma part, c'est la division des
sujets. On divise les sujets. Il n'y a
plus de sujets. On fait en sorte que le
sujet soit dépossédé de ces facultés
subjectives. Permettez-moi deux
exemples. dans le domaine du management
de plus en plus de manière agressive
quand on embauche un personnel dans des
processus
[toux]
de de sélection en passant par les
ressources humaines qui sont constituées
de neurologues, de psychologues, de gens
extrêmement douésintelligence
artificielle.
Oui, exactement. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
On choisit
le le person enfin les employés à venir,
les candidats, candidates
en fonction de simulation de tests qui
consistent à étudier chez eux des
dispositions qui leur échappent. Donc ce
sont plus des sujets qui se présentent
fort d'eux-même et qui expliquent en
quoi ils sont prêts au fond à une force
de travail au profit d'un employeur dans
dans un rapport de force qui qui est
souvent défavorable mais qui néanmoins
est identifiable. Ce sont des gens qui
sont lancés dans toutes sortes de
simulations, de jeux, de de
d'interaction qui consiste à analyser
quelle personne en quelque sorte a des
dispositions qui sont conformes à une
façon de gérer la vie en entreprise. Et
cela donne lieu à
ensuite à une activité professionnelle
qui ne devrait même plus s'appeler le
travail parce que le travail consiste en
une activité qui donne lieu à une chose
qu'on appelle aussi le travail hein. Le
travail désigne nécessairement deux
choses. C'est une activité, c'est un
résultat. On peut dire voilà c'est il
cette personne-là est au travail et on
peut dire elle a fait un travail un beau
travail bon ainsi de suite. Si le
travail ne mène pas à un travail au sens
d'un accomplissement identifiable, à ce
moment-là, on est dans autre chose qu'on
appelle dans le monde professionnel des
processus. Et on est là en Europe ou au
Québec ou ailleurs, en Amérique latine à
intégrer dans notre vocabulaire
managérial des termes qui proviennent de
l'anglais et qu'on ne comprend pas.
Parce que là, désormais, on va parler de
processus dans l'entreprise ou même dans
les ministères ou dans d'autres formes,
dans d'autres structures. Et les
processus renvoient
à quelque chose qui n'est même plus du
travail, mais une sorte de de
d'articulation compressée de tout ce que
peuvent fournir des travailleurs même à
leur insu, hein, puisqu'on travaille sur
en les en morcelant leur leur imaginaire
et leur leur conscience, hein, à les
faire évoluer sous des formes qui qui
qui rendent absurdes leur prestation. à
leurs propres yeux et et les les
dépossède même de la capacité à juger de
l'absurdité de ce qu'ils font quoi, à
simplement les les intégrer de force
dans des dans des processus. Mais le
processus quand on s'y arrête en
anglais, il renvoie davantage à un verbe
qu'à un substantif. C'est-à-dire que le
processus vient du verbe to process,
hein, le le le gestionnaire est amené à
to process euh des des compétences et
tout process
qu'au fait de la digestion. C'est-à-dire
qu'on on nen est plus à gérer, on en est
à digérer comme on dit digérer de
l'information. On digère des
compétences, on digère des facultés à
travailler, on digère de la force de
travail dans des dans des articulation
qui échappent à peu près à tout le monde
en fait. Et donc on a des travailleurs,
des travailleuses qui sont même plus des
sujets, qui comprennent à peine ce qui
se passe. Vous avez et c'est dans le
domaine intellectuel aussi, vous avez
des traducteurs ou des traductrices qui
sont amenés à travailler ensemble alors
que personne se connaît hein à distance
sur un même texte en fonction de
logiciel qui ne permet même pas de dire
"Ah, j'ai fait un travail, j'ai traduit
un texte, il était dans une langue, je
l'ai transféré, je l'ai transformé en un
texte en une autre langue." On est on
est traversé par des formes des formes
de d'organisation qui sont de nature à
nous désubjectiver. Et en ce qui
concerne l'autre aspect sur les
communications, les médias, le
marketing, on a là l'excellent travail,
même si il date un peu maintenant pour
de Marie Bénild qui avait écrit "On
achève on achète bien les cerveaux" he
qui analyse par le menu toutes les
toutes toutes les conséquences, toute la
la portée de la fameuse déclaration de
Patrick Lelet, hein, ex PDG de TF1 qui
avait dit que son métier consistait à
louer du temps de cerveau disponible à
Coca-Cola. Elle s'est intéressé à au
fond à la portée à la signification
profonde de cette amené à ça
pardon.
Qu'est-ce qui nous a mené à ça ? Ben en
fait, c'est un travail euh concerté euh
et organisé de neurologues, de
psychologues, d'experts du cerveau qui
consiste à amener euh on voir des des
chaînes de télévision notamment, mais
maintenant ce serait peut-être des des
des sites internet euh euh gérés par des
grandes entreprises, hein, à accéder à
des parties du cerveau de façon à
contourner la raison, hein, le cortex
préfrontal, des formes comme ça de
séduction
des tirs croisés qui qui amènent en fait
le sujet à ne plus être un citoyen
responsable, mais au fond
un une sorte de
d'être morcelé, fragmenté, concassé et
manipulé de par ces différentes
composantes qu'on arrive à avec
lesquelles on arrive à interagir.
C'est c'est pas de tomber dans le
misérabilisme de l'impuissance
que d'avoir ce constat là. Est-ce que
c'est pas dépossédé le public de son
esprit critique, de sa capacité à
s'insurger et à dire non ?
Ah je non dans la mesure où ce que
j'essaie de décrire Oui oui, je
comprends. Mais je dirais non dans la
mesure où il s'agit là davantage de
décrire des tendances et des intentions
que qu'un état de fait. Euh il reste que
des gens écrirent et lisent des livres
euh et s'abonnent à cette chaîne euh
euh et écrivent euh
sur des sites qui sont recommandables
euh de façon à proposer des discours
critiques sur tel ou tel enjeu.
Et je dirais même qu'il y a s'il s'agit
de voir le contrechamp de ce que j'ai
décrit là, euh je dirais que par
ailleurs, on constate,
je vais oser dire en même temps, il
paraît qu'en France, on peut plus dire
en même temps si ce n'est si sinon si on
est sur internet. Mais bon voilà,
[rires]
il y a d'une part donc c ces tendances
au morcellement des sujets à
l'aliénation radicale sur un mode
scientifique et concerté et il y a par
ailleurs une
propension à
une tendance qui consiste pour les
sujets de notre époque à complexifier
dans le meilleur sens du terme le
discours politique, hein, c'est-à-dire à
aborder les choses d'une manière
plurielle.
euh en fonction de beaucoup plus de
critères que jadis de façon même à
dépasser largement le fameux axe gauche
droite c'està dire qu'il continue
d'exister heureusement dans bien des
esprits hein sur un mode disons marxiste
à l'ancienne là où on peut être
d'extrême gauche
ou anarchiste ensuite il y aurait les
socio-démocrates les les libéraux les
les la droite traditionnelle et
l'extrême droite. Il y a euh mais de
plus en plus on a tendance à bon déjà on
on tend à penser en terme de réticule.
C'està-dire que en même temps que cet
axel là, il y aura un réticule un axe
vertical qui consistera à penser la
politique selon qu'on confère beaucoup
d'importance ou à des institutions he
qui sont autoritaires ou selon qu'on
préconise des formes radicales de
libéralité hein. Donc à gauche il y aura
les libertaires, à droite les
libertariens. au bas de ce ce réticule
et en haut il y aura les tenants
d'institutions très fortes que ce soit
qu'on soit fasciste ou communiste quoi.
Euh mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est
de voir le nombre de thèmes euh par
rapport auxquels ce réticule là se
démultiplie parce qu'on l'abordera sur
un plan socio-économique, hein, mais
aussi sur
des questions sociétales, hein. Le
fameux la fameuse intersectionnalité,
hein, les minorités, la place des
minorités, quelle plaçon, le patriarcat,
ainsi de suite. Ensuite, il y aura
l'écologie parce qu'on peut très bien
être écologiste de droite ou être ou
être communiste pour une
industrialisation et un développement
progressiste de de je ne sais trop quoi
des territoires sans sans se soucier de
la question écologique. Donc il y aura
ce point-là. Ensuite, il y aura la
question de la décentralisation par
rapport aux métropoles et et le reste et
le reste. On peut décliner à l'infini de
sorte qu'aujourd'hui le positionnement
politique lorsqu'on est engagé
politiquement devient très complexe
parce que comme on on réfléchit à toutes
ces questions-là, le l'axe gauche-
droite devient davantage une sorte de
cube. Il a il est en trois dimensions à
tous les cas et c'est par rapport à tous
ces enjeuxl qu'on finit par au fond
singulariser beaucoup son engagement. Et
le problème maintenant, il y a une sorte
de divorce entre un engagement politique
qui est de plus en plus complexe, qui
est de plus en plus fin aussi, qui est
de plus qui se décline euh selon de plus
en plus de thèmes,
et qui est en quelque sorte confronté
sur un mode masse médiatique, un
discours qui est de plus en plus
stupide, simpliste,
cadencé,
sloganesque
et fondamentalement inintéressant.
Comment fonctionnent les médias
aujourd'hui ? Surtout dans les chaînes
d'information en continu qui vandalisent
absolument les conditions de possibilité
d'un débat public. C'est en prant monter
en épingle une anecdote he je veux dire
une vitrine fracassée un 1er mai. Après
ça ce sera la déclaration malencontreuse
je ne sais trop quel ministre dans telle
occasion. Ensuite, bon, on on on on on
montr en épingle n'importe quoi pendant
36 ou 48 heures, on amènera tout le
monde à commenter l'affaire et quand la
chose se sera épuisée, on recommencera
avec un autre thème
sans sans s'attarder sur les
fondamentaux.
Absolument pas. Donc donc comment
voulez-vous que des gens qui sont
engagés politiquement qui constituent
peut-être pas la majorité mais rarement
la majorité s'est-elle vraiment
fondamentalement intéressée à la
politique ? De toute façon, elle a pu
suivre, elle a pu débattre, mais il y a
il y a toujours des je sais pas si on
doit dire des avant-gardes, mais en tout
cas des euh des des euh
des
Ouais. des précurseurs, des des des
catégories sociales qui sont plus
engagées dans le débat intellectuel et
politique et citoyen. Bon, c'est tout à
fait normal. Mais mais donc on a des des
des précurseurs ou des des des gens
politisés tout simplement dans tous les
milieux d'ailleurs qui qui se posent les
questions des questions de nature
politique et écologique d'une manière
beaucoup et sociale de manière beaucoup
plus complexe qu'avant avec beaucoup de
critères et qui sont face à une sorte de
rouleau compresseur de discursif qui est
idéologique à mort et qui dégoûte toute
personne de l'engagement civique qu'on
vient politique.
Les clives aussi non cliv les gens.
Oui ou tout à fait.
Est-ce que c'est fait à dessin le
clivage,
le fait de ne plus se rassembler et
est-ce que c'est divisé pour mieux
régner ? Est-ce que c'est euh
comme je le proposais, la division me
semble maintenant introdujective. En
fait, il s'agit même plus de diviser des
gens selon qu'ils ont un engagement
clair, mais il s'agit évidemment d'une
tendance, mais le ce qui est en cause me
semble relevé d'une d'une division des
des consciences. Une question
d'internet. Comment les humains ont-ils
pu se laisser infantiliser comme ça ?
C'est la soumission qu'on sentie.
[raclement de gorge]
J'en sais rien mais il y a peut-être une
il y a une façon qu'on peut analyser on
peut analyser la question du
divertissement par le sport.
Euh
maintenant, en fait, disons-le comme ça,
euh la politique maintenant se présente
euh d'une manière décalée.
Si j'en parlais dans l'entretien avec
Lancelin, laquelle
auquel vous faisiez référence, euh
l'idée c'est de ne pas dire ce qu'il en
est de ce régime. Si on va droit au but,
on dit les choses un peu brutalement et
fondamentalement, ce régime est
capitaliste. Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
? Ça veut dire que toutes ces
institutions et ces organisations visent
à une chose, permettre la croissance du
capital. Ça veut dire les universités,
euh les organisations dans le domaine de
la sécurité, euh les institutions
judiciaires, les parlements, les
ministères, évidemment toute
l'institution financière vise à faire
une [raclement de gorge] chose,
permettre à ceux qui ont des capitaux
d'en avoir davantage dans des processus
institués
ou de suivre une fonction exponentielle
de consommation,
mais qui sert les mêmes finalités, quoi,
c'està-dire permettre au cro à la au
capital de croître. C'est c'est
l'indicateur
ou de survivre.
Ouais, mais en fait l'objectif c'est
reste encore maintenant la croissance.
Peut-être qu'on arrivera à un point où
on on se satisfera d'un plafonnement,
mais pour l'instant, on parle encore en
terme de croissance.
Le système financier ne peut pas se
satisfaire d'un plateau.
Exactement. Oui, exactement. Donc, mais
on ne peut pas dire cela parce que ce
serait politiser ce que l'on veut
naturaliser. Alors, on fait deux choses.
D'une part, mais c'est ce que j'appelle
l'extrême centre, on puisque il s'agit
pas simplement de pouvoir public mais
d'une oligarchie qui détient en même
temps un accès privilégié à la parole
publique par des médias qui qui sont sa
propriété ainsi que des scientifiques
qui sont souvent bon des idéologues,
c'estàdire des gens qui déguisent en
connaissance des discours d'intérêt et
d'autres faiseurs d'opinion et acteurs
influents. on arrive à instaurer un
ordre qui distribue d'une manière
massive les étiquettes. Donc si vous
suivez le programme capitaliste qui
consiste en cinq points que je peux
énoncer rapidement plus de
prenez votre temps.
Oui. Plus de revenus pour les
multinationales, plus de dividendes pour
les actionnaires, plus d'accès aux
paradis fiscaux, moins de fonds pour les
services publics, moins de droits pour
les travailleuses et les travailleurs.
Du moment qu'on est dans cet axe là
qu'on s'appelle Typras, Macron ou Trump,
du moment qu'on est dans cet axe là, on
se méritera des épithètes méliorative.
C'est-à-dire qu'on nous dira euh on on
on nous passera pour moderne,
pragmatique, sérieux, responsable,
raisonnable et quoi encore normal,
courageux et le reste. Et dès qu'on
s'éloigne de cette doxa, à ce moment-là,
on passe pour hurlu berlu, paranoïque,
délirant, irresponsable, fou et quoi
encore
turbulent. Oui, voilà. Violent. Bon euh
ça c'est sur la base et donc l'extrême
centre vise non pas à situer le discours
sur l'axe gauche- droite ou sur un axe
quelconque ou dans un volume quelconque
de de référence, il vise simplement à
supprimer toute pensée politique au
profit d'un ordre qui est présenté comme
le seul valable, le seul qui puisse
exister. Bon et à cette à ce comment
dire ce phénomène là qui est plutôt un
phénomène lié à l'étos hein parce qu'on
décale la chose, on n'est plus sur le
plan des idées. Il ne faut pas y
arriver. Il faut simplement décaler la
chose et faire porter le débat sur
d'autres enjeux. Donc l'attitude.
Ensuite, il y a la question des
émotions. C'està dire qu'on présentera
ensuite sur un mode euh dire sur selon
une déclinaison gauche droite des
émotions. Est-ce qu'on est colérique ?
Est-ce qu'on est indigné ? Est-ce qu'on
est enjoué ? est-ce qu'on est anxieux ou
est-ce qu'on est haineux ? Et c'est ce
qui fera qu'on on aura ensuite en
quelque sorte une offre politique
correspondante dans toujours dans une
présentation quasi officielle des
choses. Et exemple pour revenir à la
question, c'est ça qui est
infantilisant. Ce qui est infantilisant,
c'est de nous faire passer toujours par
en quelque sorte des une sorte de
dictate moral quoi. Comment se comporter
dans le monde ? Quel quel en quelque
sorte quel discours tenir pour bien
paraître ? en quelque sorte se conformé
à la monnaie du sens qui aura été en
quelque sorte étalonnée par les grands
médias et d'autre part quel quel
sentiment
et quel sentiment alimenté et bien
entendu qu'il s'agit toujours pour bon
des des des organisations influentes
dans un espace pareil de d'associer ce
qui est en viable à à la à l'axiologie
euh
désiré. Donc effectivement au centre,
vous aurez quelqu'un au centre au
prétendu centre à l'extrême centre vous
aurez un Emmanuel Macron ici ou un
Justin Trudeau chez nous he qui fera
quoi ? Il vous proposera de la joie. De
la joie
penser printemps
de la de la joie de la la foi. La foi en
l'avenir, la beauté la jeunesse. C'est
pas le temps de parler du programme,
c'est c'est pas le temps de parler des
enjeux, c'est pas le temps de parler des
intentions, c'est le temps de de baigner
dans une sorte de de
d'état d'état d'esprit. Et ce que c'est
ce qu'on viendra à vendre. Et cela nous
rappelle la fameuse campagne euh
référendaire en Argentine qui euh avait
débouché sur le nom à la reconduite des
au au pouvoir de Pinochet qui qui a
retablé beaucoup sur la joie aussi. Il y
a eu le film N là il y a quelques années
qui
vous serez où ? serait où et comment
quand il va falloir payer la facture
de cette course en avant énergétique, de
cette consommation
exponentielle, de cette
c'est pas tout à fait du ressort de mes
compétences, je pourrais toujours citer
euh en seconde main des gens qui qui ont
traité de la question. Pour ma part, je
pense que ce qui lui est important de de
mettre en avant, ce sont des modèles
autres sur les échelles qui
sont à notre portée dans le cadre de
projet, de tentative, que ce soit en
ville ou dans le domaine rural ou
côtier, de s'essayer à autre chose
autant que faire ce peu.
Et est-ce que ce cette autre
[raclement de gorge] chose
pourra survivre à à un point de nos
retours ? Ma grand-mère avait pour
habitude de dire quand il n'y a plus de
foin dans les rateliers, les chevaux se
battent.
Je parlais à quelqu'un qui a aujourd'hui
près de 70 ans et il me rappelait que
enfin il se baignait dans le cour d'eau
qui se trouvait derrière
le domaine familial. Il pouvait boire
cette eau. Aujourd'hui, il y a des
crabes verts, il y a des algues bleues.
Euh et se demander comment on a pu en
une génération à ce point euh saccager
des écosystèmes.
Mais vous savez, moi j'en viens à ces
questions-là sur le tard. J'en suis ces
jours-ci, ces mois-ci à m'y intéresser.
Je suis arrivé par des conséquences
logiques. Je suis pas du tout
environnementaliste si vous voulez, mais
ce qui là où j'y arrive par contre,
c'est par rapport à mon travail
en en pensée politique ou en philosophie
sur la notion d'économie. Euh je fais un
grand détour, mais vous verrez, je vais
revenir à l'écologie. Euh
quand on
on a du point de vue de la conscience,
et du vocabulaire, la la des lexiques
qui nous gouvernent en fait, qui
régissent nos vies parce qu'on est
conditionné par le langage, euh on on
nous sommes laisés de ce que des
professionnels qui se sont présentés
comme des économistes
euh est en quelque sorte dévoyé
tout le vocabulaire relatif à l'économie
est réduit à ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'intendance. Ce qu'on appelle économie
aujourd'hui en fait renvoie sur un mode
tout à fait étriqué à un champ régional
qui est celui de l'intendance,
l'administration, la gestion, le
commerce, la production, la
consommation. Mais l'économie a été
continue d'être un terme et un ensemble
de de de sè he autour de la circulation,
de l'investissement, la valeur qui
existe dans main
dans m disciplines scientifiques et dans
même pratique culturell. Par exemple,
avant de parler d'écologie, on disait
l'économie de la nature. Et qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ? Ça veut dire que
avant avant que ce mot soit récupéré par
des économistes qui de j'aurais envie de
dire par des formation professionnelle
en ont fait
un fait de propriété et ont en quelque
sorte breveté le sens de tout ce
vocabulaire pour ensuite faire en sorte
qu'on ait l'impression de commettre des
métaphores dès lors qu'on parlait
d'économie autrement que dans ce
secteurlà. Le mot économie euh d'une
manière très large et euh diversifiée
renvoyé au fait des relations bonnes,
des relations escompté entre des choses
et l'économie de la nature au 18e siècle
quand on lit euh Carl von Liné, Gilbert
White ou un peu plus tard même Charles
Darwin, l'économie de la nature renvoie
une pensée sur la façon dont les
éléments entrent en relation les uns
avec les autres au gré des saisons, des
conjonctures, des circonstances pour
faire en sorte sorte que bonhom mal la
vie se perpétue dans des ensembles
souvent précaires assez étranges. Par
exemple, lorsqu'une vache ayant chaud
va se rafraîchir en plant ses pattes
dans un marais,
elle fait tomber les microbes qui
nourrissent les poissons. Et donc
Gilbert dit
la nature est une économiste. elle
arrive à organiser à mettre en relation
les choses et ce concept d'économie
renvoie à la théologie qui est une façon
de penser au fond le rapport entre les
éléments
contingents par lesquels on essaie de
traduire des principes supérieurs en
l'occurrence théologique ou divin. Et ce
concept là théologique d'économie,
l'économie étant ce renvoie entre un
vitrail, une fable, une institution, un
temple et par ailleurs un principe qui
n'est en quelque sorte perceptible que
par ces médiations là, mais qui confè
l'autorité dont on besoin ces médiations
pour peser. Ce concept d'économie
lui-même renvoie à l'usage qu'on en
faisait chez les Grecs anciens en
médecine, en rhétorique. Bon, ainsi de
suite tout ça pour dire que la notion
d'économie renvoie toute autre chose que
ce qu'on en a fait et elle est même pour
nous, je voudrais pas abuser du
vocabulaire théologique mais quelque
chose comme un salut c'està dire quelque
chose comme une perspective que l'on
pourrait investir aussi sur un plan
psychanalytique aussi sur un un plan
sémiologique aussi sur un plan
sociologique pour prendre sur nous ce
que
ce dont on nous a privé par rapport à
l'économie c'estàd la politique prendre
sur nous ce qu'il on est des formes
d'organisation qui sont les nôtres et
penser les fins en fonction desquelles
nous voulons mettre en relation des
choses. C'est tout simplement ça
l'économie en en en à tous égards. C'est
une pensée multiple
déployée
quant à une quantité impressionnante de
domaines he qui consiste à prendre sur
soi la façon dont nous organisons les
choses en fonction de fin que nous nous
donnons. Et le problème de l'économie
aujourd'hui, c'est que non seulement on
le restreinte au champ régional de
l'intendance, mais en plus on l'a
subordonné à un principe
algébrique, mathématique, scientifique
en disant l'économie ça vous dépasse.
L'économie, vous n'y comprenez rien.
C'est une science. C'est une science
assez complexe. Il faut vraiment avoir
étudié longtemps. Rassurez-vous, des
experts s'en acquitent, des gens s'en
occupent et c'est une sorte de d'alliage
entre les mathématiques, l'intendance et
le capitalisme. Et on a fait une sorte
de discours qui transcendait en la
pensée et l'agir politique de même que
l'éthique. et on a en quelque sorte au
don de cette science subordonner un très
grand nombre d'institutions publiques et
de structures
au fin d'intérêt d'une oligarchie. Vous
vous intéressez un petit peu à la
thermodynamique
de loin.
De loin ? Bon, j'ouvre une parenthèse.
L'éducation, qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
avec l'éducation pour changer tout ça ?
parce qu'il faut attendre un élément
exotique fédérateur pour que les gens
prennent conscience que ça fait 40 ans
que on les bassine avec les mêmes
théories pour servir un système ou
est-ce que Allez-y.
Ben là aussi ça, on n'est pas tout à
fait dans mon mon domaine mais s'il
s'agit de citer des textes qui
qui
m'interpelle, il y aurait le le maître
ignorant de de Jacques Rancier qui qui
renvoie l'expérience de Joseph Jacotou
qui est ce professeur dans dans la la si
je ne m'abuse dans la Flandre qui était
à l'époque
néerlandaise
et qui devait enseigner
à des étudiants un savoir qu'il ne
possédait pas et son choc a été de
constater que l'apprentissage est à
faire d'émancipation. On apprend par
soi-même. De la même manière qu'on
apprend à parler ou à marcher tout au
long de sa vie, on apprend par soi-même.
Et l'école n'est pas nécessairement
l'espace dans lequel on on apprend le
plus. C'estàdire qu'on peut apprendre à
partir de 1000 et une confrontation avec
le réel à tous âge. Euh et donc le
il ne s'agit pas de dire que l'école est
inutile, qu'on peut la la liquider euh
mais que l'école peut-être un espace
dans lequel comme dire à nouveau, on
enferme un jeune sujet dans le désir
d'apprendre quoi.
C'est-à-dire qu'on on crée les
conditions pour qu'il y ait ce ce cette
nécessité d'apprendre. Bon,
je veux bien qu' également, on veut dire
je sais pas si c'est une utopie
mais il reste que
toute tentative, tout projet, tout tout
euh tout toute initiative qui s'éloigne
de l'idée qu'on apprend à des élèves à
se conformer aux attentes d'un marché du
travail,
mérite attention et le problème
actuellement c'est de former des gens
pour un marché du travail. Vous avez
tellement d'entreprises, des
multinationales, des grandes
institutions financières, des cabinets
d'avocats qui financent l'université,
qui financent euh des institutions
d'enseignement dans le monde, même aux
États-Unis, au Canada, des des écoles
secondaires euh en fournissant du
matériel scolaire, ainsi de suite, des
des soutiens de de tout genre. euh
de façon en quelque sorte à enfermer
l'école euh et les institutions de
recherche de pointe dans une stricte
perspective capitalistique qui consiste
à produire du
savoir en fonction de ses intérêts. dans
le domaine par exemple du génie et
la géologie, si on a des techniciens qui
n'ont pas d'autre conscience et
connaissance que ce qui relève du plan
du domaine technique et qui n'ont pas
comment dire qui sont ne sont pas
invités à réfléchir sur le plan de la
citoyenneté, sur les incidences de leur
connaissances sur un réel social et et
et politique, euh on est face à des à
des acteurs sociaux qu'on qu'on invite à
à se voir strictement comme des experts
et non des intellectuels. Bon, c'est
question d'Internet, comment devient-on
philosophe ?
Patrice Lotu disait qu'on est que la
philosophie n'est pas étrangère au
trauma.
Euh c'est quand
euh c'est quand on se quand on se sent
euh
contraint
euh d'une manière impérieuse là de faire
une halte sur ce qu'on nous dit. Tout
d'un coup les choses ne tournent pas
rondement et ça peut être autant le
conducteur d'un autobus qui d'un autocar
qui ne peut pas se satisfaire de
simplement tourner en rond dans son
circuit. Je veux dire, ça peut être euh
un un pianiste qui euh ne peut pas se
satisfaire simplement de jouer ses
games, d'amour
éventuellement. Oui, ça peut être des
événements des des des événements plus
existentiels, mais il s'agit de moment
où les choses ne peuvent pas simplement
s'enchaîner comme on nous les présente.
C'est-à-dire qu'on fait subir une halte
critique à un vocabulaire, à des
pratiques parce que soudainement elles
ne nous paraissent pas évidentes. Et
cela nous amène donc à à
changer de cap, à dévier d'une
trajectoire indiquée, à s'arrêter et à,
j'aurais envie de dire commettre des
lectures, hein, que les gens les gens
bien et les gens de bien désavoureront
tout simplement parce que elles sont
elles s'intègrent pas aux activités qui
font augmenter le PIB, parce qu'elles ne
semble pas sérieuses en dire l'irbau de
l'air ou Hegel ou Aristote à 23 ans
n'est pas de nature à le plus souvent à
rassurer les parents. Bon mais s'il
s'agit du devenir, il s'agit très
souvent de de choc quoi. C'estàd qu'on
se pose des questions qui qui ne
devraient pas être au fond et qu'on mais
qui s'impose étant donné étant donné
très souvent qu'on comprend que qu'on
nous manque, qu'on comprend que ça ça ne
peut pas les choses ne peuvent pas
tourner aussi rondement qu'on nous le
dit.
Les préconisations que vous avez que
vous pouvez faire auprès des
gouvernements, est-ce qu'elles sont
écoutées ? Est-ce que vous êtes consulté
? Est-ce que vous passez pour un doux
hurlu berlu anarchiste, philosophe ou
quelqu'un de sensé ?
Oh, sur les question des paradis
fiscaux, j'ai pu à être
ici surtout au Québec et au Canada
consulté mais davantage par des partis
d'opposition.
Euh mais euh il y a je dirais qu'il y a
l'impression que chaque enjeu auquel on
peut s'intéresser suppose aussi un
cadrage approprié. Euh pour ma part, je
n'arrive pas avec une sorte de d'idée
toute faite sur la façon dont on doit
procéder quant à au à l'engagement dans
telle ou telle question. par exemple sur
les les ce qu'il en est de l'université,
je peux être beaucoup plus euh
intransigent que ce qui en est des
paradis fiscaux parce que j'ai pensé je
vais aborder cette questionlà que la
question des paradis fiscaux méritait
d'être abordé d'une manière
transversale. Je n'ai pas voulu en
quelque sorte dans l'engagement public
qui a été le mien surtout au Québec et
au Canada présenter la la lutte aux
paradis fiscaux comme étant l'apanage
d'un parti prix politique
étriqué. Euh j'ai souhaité que des gens
avec qui je ne partage pas beaucoup de
choses en ce qui concerne euh euh les
les pratiques professionnelles et les
modalités de pensée néanmoins soit
outillé sur la question des paradis
fiscaux puisqu'il s'agit d'un enjeu
commun qui mérite d'être abordé le plus
largement possible. Donc oui, des partis
politiques m'ont amené à à en parler. Ce
que j'ai essayé de faire surtout, c'est
de montrer que les paradis fiscaux et
surtout les législations de complaisance
euh c'est-à-dire aussi les ports francs
qui permettent l'immatriculation de
navire dans des conditions ultra
permissives, les zes franches qui
permettent le travail
sans aucune forme d'encadrement
contraignant. C'est dire on peut on peut
faire travailler des enfants très
souvent ou il y a pas droit la
syndicalisation quand il s'agit pas
d'autres paradis réglementaires dans le
domaine de l'assurance, dans le domaine
de la finance dans le domaine de
l'industrie minière l'immatriculation de
plateforme pétrolière dans le domaine du
pourriel du paris sportif par exemple et
autres je me suis intéressé ce que j'ai
essayé de voir c'est comment en fait les
législations de complaisance les paradis
fiscaux notamment constituent une sorte
de
rég une sorte un deuxième régime de
souveraineté constitué de quelques 80
états qui permettent au aux oligarques
de contourner
les contraintes publiques.
Euh et bon, il y aurait tellement à
dire, je ferai pas un exposé ici là, ça
durerait 2 heures, mais une je dirais
qu'il y a deux enjeux importants quant à
la question des paradis fiscaux là. La
première c'est qu'il nous coûte très
très cher sur un plan fiscal bien
au-delà de des évaluations qu'on peut
faire en monnaie sonnante et
tribuchantes. En France, on va dire
voilà, les paradis fiscaux coûtent à la
République entre 60 et 80 milliards par
an. Mais ça ce n'est que le début parce
qu'après vous avez un gouvernement celui
de la République en marche qui euh imite
les paradis fiscaux parce qu'on fait la
concurrence aux paradis fiscaux. On veut
pas que les les capitaux fui. Alors,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On fait comme les
législations de complaisance. C'estàd
qu'on on fait disparaître les revenus
financiers de l'impôt sur la fortune. On
réduit le taux d'imposition sur les
sociétés, on fait disparaître la taxe de
départ, l'exit l'exit taxe. Euh donc ça
fait toujours moins de coffres dans de
moins de fonds dans le trésor public. Et
ensuite, ben euh quand vient le temps de
boucler le budget, euh il y a déficit,
on emprunte aux instances qu'on impose
plus, c'est le monde à l'envers. Ce sont
les contribuables qui financent le
capital.
La guerre économique, vous êtes
intéressé à ce sujet-là.
Est-ce que Est-ce que un chômeur coûte
plus cher qu'un mort ?
Ce que je dirais tout simplement sur
dans cette perspective euh
c'est que dans ce régime là, on
ce régime qui qui est le nôtre, qu'on
soit chômeur ou paysan malien ou euh
marin ukrainien euh ou mineurs euh
colombien,
on obtiendra quoi que ce soit que si on
est en mesure d'établir un rapport de
force. Bon et si ce n'est pas le cas, on
tombe dans les oubliette de du du
région.
Vous entendez quoi par rapport de force
syndical ?
Les syndicats font leur taf.
[raclement de gorge]
Bah ça j'ai énuméré beaucoup de de cas
de figure en Occident. les
chez nous en tous les cas les syndicats
ont été amenés, encouragés,
contraints euh à participer à la
gouvernance, c'est-à-dire à être une
composante de la gestion du du régime
de l'apaisement social ou de la
prolongement des luttes. l'apaisement
social, c'est-à-dire qu'on on a je veux
pas caricaturer non plus, c'est c'est
complexe, mais il reste que euh dans les
années 1990,
on a assisté à à
une sorte de on on a vu le les acteurs
syndicaux être à la croisée des chemins,
c'est-à-dire ou bien on continuait à
penser sur un mode international, c'est
dire un rapport mondial entre le
prolétariat, la classe moyenne qui est
un prolétariat avec de l'argent et des
avantages qui sont en quelque sorte
prêté et le capital pour dire les choses
crument et
plutôt que de procéder ainsi par des
solidarités fortes avec des camarades de
différents pays, on on a on a assisté à
une dynamique
nationale qui consistait à dire nous
allons faire bloc avec nos patrons pour
être concurrentiel dans la
mondialisation
en tout en essayant dans ce rapport de
force là d'obtenir des avantages et je
pense pas que ça a été à au bénéfice de
de de des des travailleurs occidentaux.
Revenons à la guerre économique. Ça vous
fait penser à quoi ? Comment vous la
modélisez ? Euh
ben la guerre est c'est pas c'est pas
une expression que j'utilise hein. Euh
euh
c'est sûr que tous les jours pour aller
faire ses courses c'est compliqué hein.
La guerre économique
ce que je n'aime pas de cette expression
là c'est qu'elle elle ne permet pas de
prendre en considération les
convergences.
Quel type
entre les multinationales par exemple.
Est-ce qu'il y a guerre économique dans
le domaine pharmaceutique quand les
actionnaires des sociétés
pharmaceutiques sont à peu près les
mêmes ? Est-ce qu'il y a guerre
économique dans le domaine pétrolier
quand toutes les les grandes sociétés
pétrolières du monde sont à la fois
concurrentes et partenaires selon les
chantiers ? Est-ce qu'il y a guerre
économique on considère à Bruxelles que
qu'énormément de lobby
agissent de manière groupée dans des
secteurs par rapport à des enjeux, par
rapport à des thèmes, par rapport à des
projets de de directive par exemple ?
Il y a il y a à la fois, je dirais
quand on considère les acteurs
économiques,
les multinationales et les grandes
banques
qu'on pourrait inscrire dans la
catégorie de l'oligarchie, on voit en
elle à la fois des acteurs capables dans
un un jeu de reconnaissance diplomatique
he de ce des acteurs qui sont capables
de en quelque sorte de de s'unifier,
hein, et de créer des espèces de
cartels. Et dans ce cartel, mais un
cartel c'est peut-être trop dire, mais
en tout cas des on pourrait dire
comprendre sur le mode des intérêts bien
compris quelle est la convergence des
grands intérêts dans dans le domaine
l'agroalimentaire, dans le domaine de
l'énergie, dans le domaine bancaire,
dans le domaine des médias, du
divertissement et en même temps que on
assiste à toutes ces synergies, il y a
concurrence
mais il y a concurrence dans un une
certaine dans un certain type de
partenariat pour exclure tout nouvel
arrivant quoi. C'està dire qu'on essaie
de se partager et de fusionner et d'être
le moins possible à partager au fond les
les les profits et dividendes
pharamineux qui sont qui se dégagent de
ce type de d'organisation.
Euh et en en en même temps en essayant
de dans ce cette arène effectivement de
tirer euh un maximum de profit.
Est-ce que vous avez identifié une
sociologie de la upper classe ? Est-ce
que vous avez identifié des groupes de
pression, des des clubs de pression, des
choses comme ça ?
ce que je
ce que mon travail m'a amené à observer,
c'est
le développement des multinationales
comme des souverainetés d'un genre
nouveau. La multinationale est déjà un
extrait territorialité de de la loi,
c'est ça ?
Ben la multinationale, qu'est-ce que
c'est ? C'est une c'est déjà c'est une
c'est une pieuvre, c'est un hydre. C'est
que dire d'une multinationale, nommez,
imaginez euh
n'importe n'importe quelle structure que
vous vouliez, Amazon, Monsanto, Total,
Google, Boeing. Une multinationale n'est
jamais une entité une. C'est pas la
pizzeraia du coin là. Une multinationale
est une entité qui par définition existe
de toutes les de tous les côtés des
frontières géopolitiques. Une
multinationale est déjà partout et en
droit, elle n'existe pas. Total n'existe
pas. Ce qui existe c'est 934 sociétés
solidaires du point de vue financier
mais indépendantes et autonome du point
de vue du droit. Un groupe n'est pas un
sujet de droit. McDonald's n'existe pas.
Coca-Cola n'existe pas parce qu'existe
une myiade d'entités. Et les dirigeants
qui coordonnent l'activité de toutes ces
entités là vous diront ben nous on agit
légalement. C'est-à-dire que nous
respectons le droit euh Qatarie au
Qatar. Nous respectons le droit
bermudien au Bermude. Nous respectons le
droit russe en Russie. Euh donc en fond,
ces groupes ont euh la chance,
contrairement à la pizzaria du coin,
d'inscrire des capitaux, euh de mener
des activités dans les législations qui
sont les plus permissives et de choisir
continuellement où est-ce qu'on va
inscrire quoi pour profiter des
différents cadres législatifs qui
s'offrent à soi. Et en cela, ces
pouvoirs qui sont morcelés, qui sont
risomatiques sont capables de peser de
tous leurs poids pays par pays, là où on
les trouve filiale par filiale, sans
néanmoins faire face à quelque
contrepouvoir que ce soit parce qu'il y
a aucune législation qui elle est
capable de légiférer à l'échelle sur
laquelle se déploie la multinationale.
Et donc, elle devient une sorte de
pouvoir souverain qui va bénéficier de
tête à tête avec des chefs d'état. Vous
voyez Patrick Pouyané reçu par Vladimir
Poutine dans un cadre euh tout à fait
formel qui donne à penser les rapport
que qu' le Cremelin avec n'importe quel
autre chef d'état. Il y aura une
déclaration à la fin, un communiqué de
presse dans lequel le président de de
Total dira que lorsqu'il parle, c'est un
peu la France elle-même qui parle. Euh
vous aurez par ailleurs euh la firme qui
euh qui peut signer l'accord de la COP
21, euh faire jouer hein ses son
influence au Moyen-Orient, euh aller du
côté des Chinois quand les Américains
sont fâchés contre les Russes et à
l'intérieur de l'hexagone euh financer
les industries de telle région qui bat
un peu de l'aile. financer la
restauration d'une pièce au Louvre,
financer un centre de recherche, offrir
des bourses d'études à à des étudiants,
offrir au président François Hollande
une piste d'atterrissage à la sortie de
l'Élysée, c'estàdire la France s'engage
qui est financée majoritairement par
total et et donc devenir une sorte de
paramistère paraétat par ministère de la
culture, de la santé, de l'aménagement
du territoire, des affaires sociales et
donc devenir une sorte de pouvoir de
connexion de veuillez vous connecter et
réessayer.
À la fin de tout ça, quand on accélère
le le prisme de lecture, euh il y a quoi
à la fin ? Il y a une concentration de
la upper classe, ce qui est déjà le cas.
Mais quand on regarde les les ressources
dans dans une terre qui est finie, le
gâteau avant on partait en Amérique
chercher la croissance, ce qui a donné
le Québec, le Canada. Là, on va on va
faire quoi ? On va partir dans l'espace.
Si on peut pas partir dans l'espace,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Cette
concentration des pouvoirs des
multinationales, à la fin, elles vont
faire quoi ? Elles vont se concentrer ?
Elles vont donner qu'une seule ? Ça ça
va donner quoi ? Vous avez essayé de de
d'extrapoler votre votre scénario, votre
analyse peut-être ?
J'en suis là sans être cela dit un
chercheur empirique qui développe des
modèles
d'expérience de pensée.
Ouais, j'en suis j'en suis à dire deux
choses quoi. Tout simplement. D'une
part, c'est un modèle à bout de souffle
qui cherche à gagner du temps euh par
l'autopuasion,
par euh la restriction mentale, par
différentes formes de
prise de contrôle dialectique
et donc en en essayant par tous les
moyens de
prolonger la vie de ce régime. Bon,
je vous embête un peu. Il vous a fallu
combien de temps pour arriver à ces
conclusions ?
Donc elle saffine.
Il était clair lorsque j'ai travaillé
sur la question minière quand au Canada
euh que la destruction
provoquée par l'industrie minière ou
notamment dans la région des grands lacs
en Afrique mais aussi au Les
argent mais aussi au Pérou mais aussi en
Papoisie Nouvelle- Guinée mais aussi en
Roumanie avec quelque chose de de
destructeur. Et la question déjà que que
j'étais à même de me poser comme toute
personne qui observe ce qu'il en est il
y a il y a une dizaine d'années quand
j'ai commencé, c'était de dire que avant
de réfléchir sur l'élaboration de code
minier qui consiste à à garantir à
l'État un certain nombre de retours en
ce qui concerne l'impôt ou les droits de
douane de avant de de de de se pencher
sur les conditions dans lesquelles les
sociétés minières exploitaient des
gisements, encore fallait-il se demander
s'il est pertinente creuser
Quel intérêt a-t-il à creuser un cratère
dans lequel on peut insérer la tour
Effel si c'est pour dégager de cette
exploitation au sianure en gourmand dans
eau l'équivalent d'un de de 3 m² d'or.
Bon 3 m³ pardon, excusez-moi. Euh même
chose pour l'uranium, même chose pour
les diamants. Donc il il y a des
filières déjà qui sont ne sont pas
pertinentes du tout et qui sont
extrêmement
pertinentes peut-être si vous devez
maintenir une fonction exponentielle
à tout prix.
Oui, c'est c'est pertinente si on est
enfermé effectivement dans ce paradis.
Fuite en avant, une cavalerie.
Et si on arrête, est-ce que le
l'effondrement de cette fonction
exponentielle de consommation n'est pas
pire
que le temps qu'on gagne ? Euh oui, je
préfère pour ma part parler de
d'érosion, mais j'entends ce que vous
dites. C'est-à-dire que l'effondrement
donne à penser que quelque chose qui
vient, il y aura un cataclysme, il y
aura une catastrophe. Alors que
l'érosion euh n nous place dans une
situation où on est déjà en train
d'observer le phénomène, quoi.
C'est-à-dire que très souvent l'idée le
le la notion d'effondrement donne à
penser un château de carte quoi qui
une lente impuissance. Oui, mais là où
moi je me situerais par rapport à ce que
je fais, c'est sur la cette notion
d'économie en disant deux choses.
L'économie telle qu'elle se présente à
nous, donc dans cet enfermement dans le
secteur régional de l'intendance, dans
le champ régional de l'intendance et
dans sa soumission à des modèles
mathématiques comptables strictement
chiffrés euh liés au capital, à la
capitalisation. Cette lecture là nous
prive d'un rapport politique et éthique
à l'économie. c'est que pendant qu'on
pense l'économie comme ça, on fait
l'économie d'un très grand nombre de
considérations sensibles
et politiques. C'est qu'on nous soumet à
l'idée que l'économie est une science
plutôt que de faire l'économie un enjeu
politique, à savoir une délibération sur
les fins. Pourquoi on s'organise ?
Pourquoi on creuse ? Pourquoi on
exploite ? Pourquoi on vend à une dame
âgée qui en a pas besoin euh un vélo
dont on se servira jamais ? Pourquoi on
on pousse à la consommation ? et à
l'exploitation frité
l'obsolescance programmée. Exactement
pourquoi on accepte ça ? Et on voit bien
que l'économie en quelque sorte s
soustraite a été soustraite au champ de
la délibération politique. Et quand on
parle d'économie dans la sphère
publique, très souvent c'est strictement
pour voir comment on peut tirer partie
des en quelque sorte des des avantages
qu'on peut encore essayer de trouver
dans cette évolution idéologique là. Euh
la guerre économique.
Oui, vous pouvez moi je trouve
l'expression continue de ne pas me
parler
d'une manière nette quoi disons. Mais
mais une oligarchie très certainement
quoi qui qui soumet les gens quoi.
Est-ce que les les fous ont pris le
contrôle de l'asile ? Est-ce que les
mégalomanes
se retrouvent à la tête
pour nous gérer ? Moi, je parlerais
plutôt de pervers, c'est dire que j'ai
l'impression, mais sur un mode strict,
hein. C'est-à-dire que ce qui me semble
clair, c'est qu'il y a une façon
d'exercer le pouvoir aujourd'hui,
l'autorité, il a un rapport à la loi qui
est celui mais qui est de nature
perverse quoi, qui est celui
d'acteurs qui ont travaillé à faire en
sorte que le régime évolue sans tête,
contrairement au régime totalitaire
psychotique, à la Hitler, Staline,
Mussolini, Franco et le reste. C'està
dire qu'on a là des un régime qui est
très très fort de ce qu'il évolue sans
avoir de dirigeants clair et c'est ce
qui explique je pense
la l'engouement qu' peut y avoir
aujourd'hui pour des théories du complot
plus ou moins rigoureuses parfois
complètement fantaisistes à savoir
les gens ont besoin de croire
les gens ben des gens certains
théoriciens du complot qui moi
m'intéressent beaucoup par rapport à ce
dont ils sont le symptô
ceux qui vont croire que des lézards ou
des extraterrestres ou la CIA est
absolument toujours partout ou les 200
familles ou bon euh sur un mode disons
même pas analytique mais frénétique.
Bon, ce qui m'intéresse dans cette
attitude qui est indépendamment
d'ailleurs d'un jugement de fond dans
certains cas, c'est de voir qu'il y a
une incapacité et c'est c'est ce cela
est le symptô symptôme que c'est
intéressant. Il y a une incapacité de
dans cette chez cette catégorie
d'acteurs de d'accepter que la la case
soit vide, qu'on ne sache pas qui
décide, hein. Il y a un deuil qu'on
arrive pas à faire, à savoir celui d'un
ordre dans lequel on identifie les
décideurs. Alors, on va remplir la case
de n'importe quelle figure pour au moins
pouvoir se convaincre que quelqu'un
décide. parce que l'idée nous semble
insupportable qu'on est dans un régime
où en quelque sorte le pouvoir nous
traverse. Évidemment qu'il est il est en
quelque sorte il y a évidemment qu'il y
a des forces qui régissent l'évolution
euh de de ce régime, les
multinationales, les banques, j'en ai
parlé, les les grandes sociétés dans
dans en matière sécuritaire, le crime
organisé, ainsi de suite. Il y a des
forces mais a il y a personne a aucun
souverain à l'ancienne qui à la à la
Hitler ou à la Louis XIV dire pouvait
dire donner l'impression parce que
encore c'est c'est plus complexe mais
donner l'impression d'être le
dépositaire de la décision publique. On
en est plus là. on est dans un mode
pervers où au fond les les pouvoirs, les
puissants, les grandes banques, les
multinationales et les autres acteurs
euh
ayant plusieurs leviers à leur portée
euh on sent à euh déjà côtoyé ces
gens-là,
on sent à euh davantage à s'adapter aux
conjonctures plutôt qu'à commander hein,
ce qui doit en être. C'està dire qu'il
s'agit de de de s'adapter, c'està-dire
de de de de faire en sorte que si par de
de s'assurer que si tout d'un coup la
filière du pétrole bas de l'aile, on
sera déjà dans le domaine du gaz euh et
dans le domaine des agrocarburants et
quoi encore euh que si tandis que les
OGM génèrent un engouement pour le bio,
on sera là aussi pour fournir ces
clientèles là. S'il y a des tensions
entre la Russie et les États-Unis, on
aura comme partenaire la Chine et le
Qatar. L'idée c'est d'être capable de
tirer son épingle du jeu de toutes les
conjonctures donnant une impression de
liberté hein et de naturalité à
l'évolution des choses étant donné et
étant donné sa capacité à s'adapter
plutôt qu'à diriger. Et c'est ce qui je
dirais caractérise ce régime.
Vous avez déjà côtoyé ces gens-là, la
haute finance, la classe, les les les
gens décideurs.
Vous avez déjà fait une petite soirée
sur un yach avec trois quatre mannequins
pour voir un petit peu comment ces
gens-là réfléchissaient ou ça ça ne fait
que
partie de de vos prospectives dans les
livres ? C'est est-ce qu'il y a une
enquête de terrain pour connaître la
psychologie de ces gens-là ?
Ben d'une part bon très peu. Je pourrais
vous citer des anecdotes serait pas très
intéressant. Si
si si si. Bon, j'ai pu euh dans le cadre
de négociation de nation judiciaire voir
de très près euh des euh des
représentants de société minière et
leurs avocats qui me semblaient être et
je le dis en pesant mes mots, mais
d'autantique fasciste là, c'est-à-dire
au sens une définition, au sens où euh
ces gens ces gens ne conçoivent pas que
quelque chose puisse résister à leur
pouvoir. dans cette optique là très
authentique hein très euh mais par
ailleurs, je je
considère je veux dire je je je ne
tout en tout en lisant beaucoup de de de
production de nature empirique des
rapports, des livres, des documentaires
et en me nourrissant de de ce travail,
ce qui m'intéresse davantage c'est de
voir en fond quel type d'analyse et
considération conceptuelle on peut en
tirer. C'està dire que si des ONG, si
des journalistes, si des militants, si
des citoyennes, des citoyens produisent
l'information sur le plan du témoignage
de du compte-rendu des des faits, la
production de fait, c'est bien pour que
des gens après coup se nourrissent de
cette information là et en fassent
quelque chose sur un autre plan qui est
conceptuel.
Vous êtes sûr ?
Pardon ?
Bah c'est c'est oui, tout à fait.
C'est-à-dire que c'est comme ça qu'on
peut comprendre euh selon quelle
modalité
euh euh fonctionne les institution de
pouvoir. Je vous donne l'exemple des
paradis fiscaux. Ce qui m'a intéressé
moi sur les paradis fiscaux, c'est pas
d'aller au Lenstein puis d'aller voir
une société écran. Euh
c'était pas non plus d'aller à Jersé,
c'était pas non plus d'aller au Panama.
C'était ce qui m'intéressait, c'était de
voir comment les sociétés les les
législations de complaisance sont
devenues tellement importantes,
tellement puissante qu'elle
qu'elle
affecte le vocabulaire qu'on utilise
pour en parler, hein. C'est-à-dire
prise de contrôle de la dialectique.
Ouais. Ben des mots comme territoire,
état, frontière, droit, lois, crime,
souveraineté, non plus la même
définition depuis que ce phénomène des
paradis fiscaux a
a gagné en expansion. Et donc là, il y a
quelque chose strictement analytique. Il
s'agit pas d'y aller. Il s'agit pas de
de rencontrer un puissant, il s'agit pas
de de suivre la trace d'un d'un fond
bancaire. Il s'agit de s'arrêter euh à
partir d'une culture qui peut être une
culture générale et aussi une culture
spécifique. Et à partir de ces
compétences là, penser le réel en
évidemment en se nourrissant de la
production empirique. Mais ce serait une
erreur que et ce serait dire pauvrement
antiintellectuel que de penser qu'il y a
que les faits qui en quelque sorte
parleraiit d'eux-même et qu'on aurait
pas besoin de gens pour en comprendre la
porter. Et ce qui est intéressant dans
un travail analytique, c'est de produire
une réflexion qui n'est pas seulement la
somme des parties he qu'on a requis pour
pour y arriver. [grognement]
On arrive à la fin de notre émission. On
a pour habitude de poser une question
qui n'est pas une question qui est
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, des préconisations, euh des
solutions ?
Euh ouais, c'est pas trop dans mes
habitudes. J'aurais j'aurais envie de
dire euh n'écoutez pas les conseils
qu'on vous donne.
Euh mais euh mais mais moi je dirais
pour moi-même en tout cas quelque chose
qui a pu euh qui a pu compter, c'est
cette idée euh
que les mots sont plus forts que nous.
Euh les les mots avec lesquels on
pactise, les milieux dans lesquels on
s'inscrit sont plus forts que nous.
C'est-à-dire que dès lors qu'on pactise
avec un certain vocabulaire, dès lors
qu'on consent à appartenir à un certain
milieu, c'est ce vocabulaire et ce
milieu nous conditionneront.
Et la seule la principale liberté qu'on
a, c'est de choisir avec quel
vocabulaire et avec quel milieu on on
entre en relation sur un plan
intellectuel et intime.
A de merci.
Merci à vous.
Coup.